Your cult
fractured
Our people.
All right, kid.
Hang on.
You're ready for an adventure.
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie.
This is the way.
This will be my Mandalorian.
Season three Episode five Trailer Video.
There's a whole bunch of Easter eggs and
references, so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
I'm doing videos for all the episodes.
Be sure to subscribe to get them.
Some of the new footage here could be from
other episodes in the future,
because both Marvel and Star Wars do this
weird thing with all their trailers
for episodes, mixing footage
from all the episodes together sometimes
as opposed to HBO
for their episode trailers,
where you just usually get footage
from that one particular episode.
But there's a lot of new
footage of the Pirates maybe flashbacks
to Mandalore before the Purge, maybe
for some more Bo Katan backstory,
A ton more footage of the armors group
fighting Gorian Shards
Pirates on Navarro, More footage
of Mando dog
fighting his pirate ships in his cruiser.
Some new footage of Carson Teva
coming back from previous seasons
and what looks like
more footage of Elia Kane.
Moff Gideon, former comms officer
with a special cameo from Tim Meadows.
In the background here, just starting
with the end of episode four.
That episode was mostly about Bo Katan
and Grogu becoming more active parts
of the armors, covert integrating
with the covert in a bigger way.
Bo Katan helping them by Save Ragnar,
the heavy infantryman paths Vizsla son
and bringing in those three winged
raptors cannot wait to see grogu
who tame them and then ride one of them
once they get big enough.
I could definitely picture Grogu
flying around on one of their backs
in Grogu who's starting his training
to become a mandalorian.
Like the armor, recognizing his quest
to become a mandalorian,
or at least implying that
that's where he's headed.
Katy Sackhoff talked a little bit
more about Bo Katan joining the Armorer's
cover two.
She said her night owls had deserted her.
Those were meant to be like
her family to Bo Katan.
They left her after
she didn't return with the Darksaber.
So according to her at the time, they
didn't view her as a worthy leader yet.
So key word here is yet.
I think the whole storyline with the myth
they saw in the armor,
not believing her in her not thinking it
the moment that she is a worthy leader.
Caity
Sackhoff said that like at the moment
Bo Katan doesn't think that she is worthy
to lead all mandalorians,
Which is why
when she was talking to the Mando
initially,
she kind of threw that in his face, like,
Go take the darksaber
wave it in their face.
They'll do whatever you say, as if she had
given up carrying about being a leader.
So I think the idea with her
character is becoming a worthy leader.
Also, it helped a little bit
the grand Admiral Thrawn had blown up
her family's ancestral palace or was seen
like grand Admiral Thrawn forces.
Katie Sackhoff said
that she was looking for family.
She lost that when the night owls
took off, and now she's slowly becoming
kind of like a space mom
to grow, grew and joined the family
that is the armor's covert Mando's family.
Basically, space, mom and space
dad are going to take care of the child.
I make a lot of jokes about her and Mando
eventually getting it on,
but I don't actually think there's
going to be
any of those kind of shenanigans
this season.
I think all the stuff
Katie Sackhoff has talked about with her
and Grogu, who in her
being kind of motherly towards him
growing to care about him
the same way that Mando cares about him.
She isn't giving anything away
about any potential romantic entanglements
between her and Mando.
You just see some of the weird tension
between the two of them, like
they have a lot of chemistry together.
You just see more moments like that.
The whole thing with Grogu's storyline,
a lot of people wondered about this, like,
will he eventually wear a helmet
because the armor was talking about that.
Mando talked about it before his big bite,
like he won't wear the helmet
until he's old enough to speak the creed
and he's not old enough yet,
even though it does seem like he's
been trying to talk,
just using their native language.
Yoda's species, Native language.
But the armor gave him his chest plate
because he won that fight
with the Mud Hornet,
which is the symbol of Mando's
family, basically, like she even told him
you are as his father.
Now, long term,
I think his arc is similar to Bo Katan
in that
he completes more Mandalorian training,
like he integrates more with the cover,
doing more
and more of what
they're supposed to be doing
when they become mandalorians
according to their customs,
and when it actually comes time for him
to speak the creed and wear a helmet
like by that time.
Whether that happens in a future season
or further beyond, it'd be kind of
like what happened with Luke Skywalker
training at his Jedi Academy,
where he was forced to choose a path
and choosing not to become a Jedi,
choosing Mando over becoming a Jedi.
The important thing about that
too, is Luke Skywalker specifically said
choosing a path with Mando, not choosing
a path to become a mandalorian.
One of the major overarching themes of
the season in Just The Mandalorian series.
In general, having many seasons
that winds up running is that you have a
lot of different factions of Mandalorians
like the Armored faction, the Night Owls,
and none of them agree
with what they should be doing
with their customs, with their culture is
the armors group is like the most hardcore
version of Mandalorians, like old school
Mandalorians.
So eventually
what sounds like is going to happen
is the armor will give him the choice.
Like either you become a mandalorian,
now you take the creed, you wear a helmet,
or you choose a different path.
He will probably wind up
choosing a different path,
like I don't think that he's actually
going to wear one of those helmets.
For those of you asking,
his ears would probably stick out
like this,
like it would be a special helmet
that would fit his type of head
if he were to wear a helmet as cute is
that does look in a bit
kind of like this for Bo Katan as well
to wear, even though technically
she's already following all the rules
like she's already wearing her
helmet full time.
Now there's a moment with the armor where
it seems like she's not totally on board.
Like I saw amid the sword,
the armor didn't want to believe her.
So I think part of the idea
is that deep down, Bo Katan ultimately
will believe that they should be doing
different things,
following a slightly different path.
This is different from what
the armor thinks they should be doing.
So eventually she will also
probably have to leave their group too.
It'd be kind of
like an Ahsoka type of twist.
Like Ahsoka left the Jedi Order
to forge her own path through the force
and it would be the same for Bo Katan,
for Grogu, and maybe
even Mando himself too,
because Grogu's whole thing
in leaving the Jedi Academy was to choose
a path to be with Mando.
So ultimately
it sounds like the three of them
at least will become a sort of family
unit, even if they all wind up
having to leave the armor's covered.
But I'm not expecting them
to completely pay that off this season.
Like I don't think they're all going
to bail on the Armor's cover this season.
They're still trying to unite all
mandalorians that bo katan ultimate goal.
So part of
this is finding the common ground between
all the different Mandalorian factions.
We might get
some more of bo katan backstory
because the ship here flying towards
what looks like a flashback
to Mandalore before the Great Purge
is the same ship that she flies.
It might just be more backstory
we're getting that we didn't see of her
during Clone Wars or Star Wars Rebels.
Katy Sackhoff also said that there's
a lot of untold history
for Bo Katan that she talks
about with Dave Filoni on the regular.
Like she's always asking him questions
about her childhood,
like what was Bo Katan doing
before she actually became a soldier.
If we get some flashbacks for her,
maybe we'll get some more references
to the duchess,
the teen, to all the footage of them
fighting the pirates on Navarro, though,
seems like they're
dropping out of Bo Katan ship.
So it's her leading another mission,
which I think is just another step on her
path to becoming a worthy leader.
This is the same hangar bay you saw Mando
jumping out of using his jetpack.
It sounds like Richard makes good
on his threat to return and wreak havoc
on Navarro as punishment for what happened
in episode one with Mando and Greek
cargo killing a couple of their men,
basically giving him the middle finger.
It was meant to be a challenge, setting up
a bigger conflict later in the season.
It's probably this conflict.
Navarro is also a much richer place,
becoming one of the major hubs
in the Heidi in Way, which is a huge deep
cut for the Clone Wars
and some of the legends canon.
It's one of the major
trade routes in the galaxy.
So all the big ports that are part of this
get much richer from all the trade
passing through.
That's why Gorian Shard
would care about controlling this planet.
The new footage of Alia Kane
has her in her new Republic uniform.
She's looking kind of says, I'm not sure
who Timm Meadows is supposed to be.
Zoom in here
to see him in the background here.
The last we saw her in episode three,
she had cranked the neural eyes her way up
to mess with Doctor Pershing's
mind in likely causing him to forget what
she'd been doing
this whole time, entrapping him
so he wouldn't remember her
after the fact,
all so that she could continue her
probably true mission infiltrating
the New Republic and freeing Moff Gideon
from whatever deep, dark
Guantanamo Bay style prison
that they're keeping him in.
Because one of the next big things,
the imperial storyline, is revealing
what's actually going on with Moff Gideon
confirming that he's still in prison.
Because if you remember in episode three,
all the former Imperials were joking
about what actually happened to him
because nobody actually knew the truth.
I heard
he escaped en route to the war tribunal.
Now that was just the cover story I heard.
They hooked him up to a mind.
Flayer.
I try not to think about him anymore
the way they talked about it.
It sounds like Moff
Gideon is meant to have disappeared
on his way to a New Republic war tribunal.
And I think the idea is the New Republic,
which they portrayed
as being kind of shady during episode
three.
Like they made them seem as if they
weren't that much better than the Empire.
They probably bypassed
the official channels
and just threw him in a Guantanamo
Bay style prison
where they're trying
to rake him over the coals,
getting more information
on the remnants of the empire.
Like what else is going on there?
What other forces do
you have in there to continue teasing?
Thrawn I'm not expecting to get
a ton of big answers about Thrawn yet,
just more teasers that he's out there with
the Seventh Fleet rebuilding his forces,
but his storyline is meant to be connected
to Moff Gideon's So early theory.
Eliot Kane is actually working for Thrawn
doing this long con
trying to get him out of prison,
pretending to be on the New Republic side,
throwing Dr.
Pershing under the bus
so that she'll win commendations
and win her way closer
to where they're holding Moff Gideon
or be able to get closer to him,
bring him out of prison,
and he can rejoin Thrawn.
The only other huge things
that they don't show you in the trailer.
Here are what's going on with Ahsoka
and Kirsten Tiba,
who we know are supposed to come back
this season.
In the earlier trailers,
you heard Carson Teva
warning Mando about something
dangerous happening in the outer rim.
That's probably part of the larger
Thrawn storyline.
Beware of giant fleets of tie fighters,
tie interceptors and tie bombers out
there.
When Ahsoka comes back,
she might also have Sabine Wren with her.
It would be cool to get a teaser for her
live action because we saw some footage
of her in the Ahsoka trailer,
which I did a video for last year,
but they didn't release it publicly.
We're supposed to get the official Ahsoka
trailer in Star Wars celebrations.
Of course, we'll do more videos
for when it does drop,
but they're meant to be picking up where
Star Wars rebels left off in live action.
So they'll do a version of this scene
in live action.
There's also rumors
that the Ahsoka episodes will pull House
of the Dragon Twist with a major time jump
halfway through the series,
even though it's
going to be the same actors,
they're not going to be switching actors
or anything like that.
If it's any other Easter eggs
or references in the footage
that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments.
And if you have any requests
for bonus videos before episode five, post
everyone click here
for all My Mandalorian Season
three episode videos
and click here for my new Thrawn video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone. Stay safe.
This is the way.